ó
olá pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que
seja muito bem vindo é mais conferir o
bicho sua obra
oi botafogo flávio porto onde omar el
sim de night air france que este não é o
que eu gosto da minha pistola possa
administrar uma coisa que já cria muito
tempo muito tempo que são bonecos tu faz
nice ainda tá muito real muito porque
foi tudo o que eu fazia muito isso é que
eu fazer eu tenho coleção toda olha o
gol de fred o foco ache que o gol é
muito bonito fornece fred muito
há duas semanas atrás do katrina foi
proibida de state of america chat e
elásticos estão baratas portanto ela
aproveitou e comprova que este presente
seus métodos atuais são tudo fascinante
e fred eu estou feliz possível
encomendar isto é importante esse cara
pra [ __ ] mas ela comprou mais barato
e funciona
adoro a minha namorada e em cada
embalagem como vocês podem ver aqui tem
uma peça do sprint leps nós compraram
studio 5 do next nós conseguimos montar
o espírito tranqüilo aqui com o fox
exibe um corpo de luke é parte principal
e depois em cada embalagem vocês tem que
quebrar sua perna meu essa né
com o tempo porque ambiental tá igual só
estamos aqui num cenário de ambon sim
mas não só gosta gosta é eu construí
aqui mesmo especialmente pra isso espero
que vocês gostem e vamos lá então abrir
32 vamos começar aqui pelo focus porque
eu acho que faz mais sentido porque eu
venho com a peça principal do prep
sportnet flash possa começar 15 fornece
fredes figuras e construiu próprios foi
entregue é basicamente eu já expliquei à
internet um fígado vão uma peça do sul
entrega que neste caso vem à cabeça o
corpo e vejam só o linares pessoal isso
não é figura do chinês que está muito
bem feito eu tá muito detalhado não é
parte em frente a caixa se vocês
repararem que trazem todos os cincos lá
é o site fred boni tica bum e freddie
fox isso pra entrega ganhar vamos lá
então lino foxy o o sol tá muito o samba
é um só detalhe meu tá muito bom e pelo
que eu estou vendo as articulações estão
a funcionar a hoplon trata todas as
articulações mexem e remexem ombro
méxico do véu e faltar com uma mão e não
sei porque acho que a partir daí até o
promotor da mão tá bem feito eu tenho
que o gás se tudo meu muito difícil e eu
acho que essa personagem é único tem um
negócio que ela tenha assim fora você
até consegue ver aqui e tem um rasgão e
tudo meu tá muito ó sangue
esta qualidade incrível a sério tá muito
bem feito eu nunca vi um action figure
também pintada meu tá muito difícil ea
quebra de um tabu e sinistro só vou
deixar aqui um canto e vou mandar a
medida cobrindo as outras figuras é o
próximo estágio é o fred como vocês
podem ver ela até vêm aqui com o
microfone em tudo e tem uma perna se não
me engano do intrépido não eu está se
desfazendo
o fred está idêntico está muito bom é
preciso um caso de cuidado ao mexer aqui
senão as peças saem todas imagens antes
disso é que vocês podem juntar vários
animais tronics que posso chutar o braço
do fred com o braço do fox e é isso aí
alta pulsação mil ou é visando meu isto
é que ela bateu com as costas sabe ainda
podemos por um microfone meu
só uma coisa que eu não gosto dessas
figuras já que os veículos são mais
sensíveis qualquer toquinho para o nosso
intrépido começa a lancheira ok faltam
duas pernas e um braço próxima figura
born estudar o lindo talendo lindo é que
tá mesmo igual alta foi bem pintado tabu
é difícil aqui tenho uma oficial de 2016
pode ficar um campeão pelo meu oie e
voltei atrás da guitarra aí pela garra
guitarra a nelsinho braço a sério isto é
que é sensível olhar e ela te mexer nele
é meu
a escolha de borracha assim
o caio bonilha e com uma perna do
sprinter é vista bonita por acaso ela
está quase completo só falta uma perna e
um braço próximo personagem nós temos
aqui e chica e provavelmente este é um
dos meus bonecos favoritos porque porque
tem culpa porque meu está bom é que o
tabu filho
o opel comendo muita comprarem estes
vocês gostam farinati fred porque está a
sua em bem que o babete dela zelândia e
eu gostava de cabeça 6 eu acho que não
sai né eu acho que a mesma empresa lei
robin tudo ok ela também se articula
todo é igual aos outros animas roni que
está muito difícil e vem aqui o que dela
quero que pareça acho que não faz nada
34 que o jesus está até bem aqui em cima
eu tava ós eu não sei se ela conseguir
deixar aqui a foto já partiu brasil na
caraças coisas todas
acho que vai com a outra perna do dos
pré tá brutal os prep meu tá muito bom o
tempo imagens o algodão em fred e é com
esse personagem que nós vamos conseguir
acabar ali os prep da empresa está com
uma coroa vida e eu até tenho aqui tem
um detalhe que está aqui como e sujo eu
não sei explicar mas estava bem pintada
sério eu acho que ela é igual à fred é
igual à frente mas é amarelo e tem o
jorge preto acho que é só isso eu venho
aqui com microfone deu também ou
novembro uon
só vocês filha tiver algum feedback eu
vou trazer mais coisas para finais
porque eu tenho mais coisas por livros
portanto deixe você pode fazer negócio
pagar disse fred que só espero que vocês
tenham gostado já sabe enquanto os flex
brito filho nem a posse